هذا بالنسبة لفلاديمير بوتين هو ما
يبدو عليه انتصار روسي حديث مثل
عشرات القتلى أو المفقودين في
غارة جوية روسية على قرية ناطقة بالروسية
كجزء من حملة روسية يقول بوتين
إنها لحماية أقاربه في
أوكرانيا.
تخشى السلطات المحلية أن يموت حوالي 60
شخصًا هنا ، كانت هذه مدرسة في
بيلوهريفكا في شرق أوكرانيا
كان القرويون يحتمون في قبوها ،
وكان بعضهم هناك منذ أسابيع ،
ولم يترك الناجون سوى القليل من
الحزن ،
لكننا سألنا عما إذا كانت عائلته معه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق  ]
[موسيقى
] لا يغيب عن أحد هنا أنه
عشية احتفال فلاديمير بوتين
بانتصار السوفيت في
الحرب العالمية الثانية على ألمانيا النازية ، كان
المدنيون هم الأكثر
معاناة باسم نزع فلاديمير
بوتين لأوكرانيا  بلد
به رئيس يهودي ، تعرضت
للهجوم من قبل لوح منحني في
كرة ثم انفجار آخر صخور صغيرة
تناثرت في الظلام
ثم نظرت والغبار س  بعد أن تخلصت
من مجموعة من الضوء ، بدا أن
سيرجي زحف إلى الخارج ، ثم
أخرجني من الحفرة عمي تولجا حفرت العمة خارج العراق ، زحفنا
جميعًا في ضباب قال إن
أوكرانيا أوقفت خطط روسيا
للغزو ،
لذا أضاف الكرملين مواقع استراتيجية
مثل إمدادات النفط إلى هدفها  قائمة
وصعدت غاراتها الجوية ضد
المدنيين في شرق أوكرانيا هذا الأسبوع
ضربت
مجمعاً سكنياً في مدينة كراماتورسك الاستراتيجية.
النساء والأطفال الذين يغتصبون
وينهبونهم يذهبون خطوة بخطوة نحو
النازية ،
مثل هذه التفسيرات لما يحدث
هنا لا تجيب حقًا على السؤال المؤلم
لماذا
سام كيلي سي إن باكموت